[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach seinem fast drei jahrzehnte langen
dornröschenschlaf wird das gute alte in
die pollen 1 das mächtigste land des
asiatischen kontinents so langsam wieder
fit und zwar sowohl auch
wirtschaftlicher als auch auf
politischer ebene ein beispiel gefällig
nun seit dem opel aufgesetzt hat schon
klargestellt dass japan der dreh und
angelpunkt der sicherheitspolitik in
asien bleibt ein direkter beweis dafür
ist dass sowohl außenminister internet
linken als auch verteidigungsminister
lloyd austin auf ihrer ersten
auslandsreise japan besucht haben und
nicht nur das der damalige japanische
premierminister yoshihiko ist der erste
ausländische stars den beiden als
präsident im weißen haus empfängt das
ist schon eine ziemlich starke bekundung
gegenseitige verbundenheit
aber natürlich geht es nicht nur um die
beziehungen zwischen tokio washington es
waren schließlich nicht die grenzen
donald oder jo welche das fernöstliche
insel sondern wach geküsst haben
vielmehr hat ihn nicht mehr zu leugnen
oder geopolitische bedrohung sowie
wirtschaftliche konkurrenz aus china die
japanische regierung wachgerüttelt und
dazu veranlasst endlich die ärmel
hochzukrempeln und eines kann ich euch
jetzt schon verraten sie was sich
ordentlich ins zeug gelegt da wäre zum
beispiel das transpazifische
partnerschaftsabkommen tpp des der
größten freihandels und
wirtschaftsintegration abkommen der welt
dass wohl niemand anderen als sie japan
angeführt wird einem land das laut
meinungsumfragen die vertrauenswürdigste
macht in ostasien ist der am schnellsten
wachsenden wirtschaftsregionen der welt
aber wir reden hier nicht nur über den
politischen bereich die wahrheit ist
dass japan auch wirtschaftlich immer
mehr in mode kommt trotz aller
einschränkungen wie der ewigen krise den
demographischen verfall oder der
schwäche des iren er findet sich das
land der aufgehenden sonne oder besser
gesagt die japanischen unternehmen
gerade nur
[Musik]
sein ende der 1990 er jahre als zunächst
südkoreanische und taiwanesische und
chinesische unternehmen begannen mit
vielen japanischen herstellern zu
konkurrieren waren sie nach und nach
gezwungen waren zu produzieren die
schwierige herzustellen und zu imitieren
waren mit anderen worten sie mussten in
der wertschöpfungskette aufsteigen und
genau das ist ihnen auch bildungen viele
japanische unternehmen haben sich zu
lieferanten von hochtechnologie
hochgradig innovativen materialien und
komponenten entwickelt den der globalen
produktionskette unverzichtbar sind um
euch eine vorstellung davon zu geben
auch wenn die bedeutung japans für uns
endverbraucher er unsichtbar ist
kontrollieren japanische unternehmen
mehr als 50 prozent des marktanteils bei
vielen fortschrittlichen komponenten sie
dominieren damit den großteil der
lieferkette in der hightech industrie
das reicht von spezialglas über anlagen
zur herstellung von halbleitern bis hin
zu komplexen chemikalien wenn du
hightech produkte verwendet hat japan
höchstwahrscheinlich eine menge damit zu
tun und das erklärt dann in vielerlei
hinsicht war ob japans reales pro kopf
bip wachstum seit 2009 was so hoch ist
wie das der usa und höher als von
ländern wie frankreich oder
großbritannien
so sieht es aus japans bip wächst kaum
aber wir müssen berücksichtigen dass
eine bevölkerung insbesondere die im
erwerbsfähigen alter seit jahren
schrumpft mit anderen worten bei einer
geringeren arbeitnehmer und
bevölkerungszahl schafft es die
japanische industrie trotzdem mehr zu
produzieren
gemessen am pro kopf einkommen war die
wirtschaftsleistung japans in den
letzten zehn jahren also recht gut
[Musik]
und wenn wir noch berücksichtigen das
ist nach den usa und china immer noch
der drittgrößte verbrauchermarkt der
welt ist können wir uns vorstellen warum
japans wirtschaft wieder die
aufmerksamkeit vieler multinationaler
unternehmen auf sich zieht aber wartet
einen moment dann irgendwas stimmt hier
nicht trotz all seiner attraktivität ist
es so dass internationale unternehmen
kaum in japan investieren ist das nicht
kurios wenn die japanische wirtschaft so
attraktiv und konkurrenzfähig ist wieso
wollen ausländischen investoren dann
dort nicht ihr geld anlegen und an ihren
erfolg mitverdienen nun heute werden mit
diesen interessanten fragen nachgehen
über strukturelle probleme reden euch
aber auch die japanischen feiertages
vorstellen echte filmreife wirtschafts
und mafia thriller im reallife bevor wir
jedoch fortfahren erlaubt uns eine
kleine werbepause für unseren sponsor
stark einzulegen surgery bnd ist ein
wirklich sicheres vpn dass ich auch
selbst zu meiner vollsten zufriedenheit
nutzer okay aber wozu braucht man
eigentlich ein virtual private networks
vpn nun da wären gleich mehrere vorteile
zum einen erschwert es in kombination
mit anderen vorkehrungen eure aktionen
im netz nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören es
bietet unzählige sicherheitsfeatures mit
dem oder anonymität im netz erhöht zum
beispiel klien wird dass alle cookies
top auch fortgeschrittene
identifizierung nach verfolgungs
mechanischen sicher braucht um die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt weiterer
vorteil eines vpn ist dass er so tun
können als wäre er an einem anderen ort
so könnte zum beispiel auf websites und
internet dienste zugreifen in dem land
in dem er gerade seid nicht verfügbar
werden ob daheim oder im urlaub damit
schlag der zensur und geo blocking ein
schnäppchen netflix und andere streaming
dienste die ihre inhalte nur in den usa
anbieten von europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches internet fernsehen im ausland
gucken mit surf shop kein problem aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles denn mit
nur einem server konnte könnt ihr
wirklich alle endgeräte in foren
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
euren smart tvs so und wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angibt bekommt ihr
von 12 auch noch einen rabatt rund 83
prozent und obendrein den ersten drei
monate gratis dazu den link zu diesem
angebot findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter diesem video also nichts wie los
besonders eröffnen doch gleich sich um
uns finanziell unter die arme wir sind
euch für jede unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätte er uns euch in zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere videos zu liefern
so und nun zurück nach nippon und zu
unserer bränden frage
warum investiert niemand in japan
ok zu sagen dass überhaupt niemand in
japan investiert wäre natürlich
übertrieben aber ihr werdet es sicher
nicht für eine übertreibung halten wenn
ich euch sage dass die vereinten
nationen japan nach nordkorea auf den
vorletzten platz in der welt setzen was
die ausländischen direktinvestitionen in
prozent des bip an geht das stellt schon
eine verdammt große und überaus
bemerkenswerte anomalie da nicht wahr
nur mal so zum vergleich die
ausländischen direktinvestitionen in
japan machen etwas mehr als vier prozent
des dortigen bip aus der durchschnitt
der industrieländer liegt jedoch bei
sage und schreibe 44 prozent und damit
könnt ihr schon ein erstes bild davon
machen mit welch krassen gefälle wie es
hier zu tun haben aber das ist noch
nicht alles normalerweise würden länder
die ihr wirtschaftswachstum ankurbeln
wollen ausländische unternehmen
ermutigen sich dort anzusiedeln neuer
einrichtungen wie neue fabriken oder
büros eröffnen lokale unternehmen zu
kaufen oder öffentliche oder private
anleihen des landes zu investieren wenn
japan ist dies jedoch nicht der fall
denn das land ist nach wie vor völlig
von den ausländischen
direktinvestitionen strömen abgekoppelt
aber heißt das nun dass es irgendwie
verboten ist im land der aufgehenden
sonne produktiv zu investieren nein ganz
und gar nicht tatsächlich sprechen
japans politiker schon seit fast 20
jahren davon ausländische investoren
anlocken zu wollen und da zu fördern und
in gewisser weise haben sie das auch
getan
[Musik]
als co-lead ihrer konsumiert 2001 sein
amt als premierminister antrag bedrucken
die authentischen direktinvestition im
land nur 12 prozent des bip woraufhin
die regierung das ziel von 5 prozent bis
zunächst lief alles glatt und der anteil
der ausländischen investitionen stieg
2008 auf 4 prozent seitdem stagnieren
die zahlen jedoch die frage ist also was
ist der grund für diese anomalie
warum zieht japan keine produktiven
investitionen an warum will niemand oder
fast niemand in diesem land investieren
wie ist es möglich dass das einzige land
das das land der aufgehenden sonne in
diesen rennen schlägt ausgerechnet
nordkorea ist nun meine lieben visual
politik fans der schlüssel zur auflösung
dieses ganzen rätsels scheint in der
kultur art und struktur der japanischen
unternehmenslandschaft selbst und der
damit verbundenen eingefahren
geschäftsprozesses zu liegen lasst mich
das erklären in einem typischen
industrieland erfolgen bis zu 80
trotzdem der zuflüsse ausländischer
direktinvestitionen in form von
unternehmensfusionen und übernahmen das
ist in japan jedoch nicht der fall es
scheint sich um ein erbe aus der zeit
unmittelbar nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
zu handeln
[Musik]
damals beschränkte tokio die
ausländischen direktinvestitionen um zu
verhindern dass ausländische unternehmen
die kontrolle über den markt übernehmen
ja später als er bei trister sed die
japanische regierung zwang diese
beschränkungen aufzuheben entwickelten
die japanischen politiker eine art
gegenmaßnahmen multinationale
unternehmen in kauf japanischer
unternehmen zu erschweren eine großer
teil dieser gegenmaßnahmen hatte mit der
förderung von überkreuzbeteiligungen
zwischen unternehmen und vor allem mit
der rückkehr der großen konglomerate der
carrer zu zu tun um euch eine
vorstellung davon zu geben diese
konglomerate eben auch heute noch eine
enorme kontrolle über die nationale
wirtschaft aus die kläre zu
kontrollieren 26.000 teilgesellschaften
56.000 tochtergesellschaft und
beschäftigen und 18 millionen menschen
was ein drittel aller japanischen
arbeitnehmer und dabei werden die den
unternehmen die als subunternehmerin
zulieferer eng mit diesen gruppen
verbunden sind noch gar nicht mitgezählt
der toyota-konzern zum beispiel hat etwa
1000 tochterunternehmen und 40.000
zulieferer von denen die meisten eng mit
dem konzern verbunden sind mit anderen
worten die sind in der praxis nicht
völlig unabhängig auf diese weise üben
die cracks eine so große kontrolle über
die gesamte japanische
unternehmenslandschaft aus dass die
ausländischen unternehmen wenig raum
lässt um fuß zu fassen es handelt sich
somit um so was wie ein staat in sich
abgeschlossenes ökosystem das problem
ist dass dieses ökosystem so
abgeschottet ist dass es in vielen
bereichen zu einer enormen in sucht
geführt hat die auf kosten von
produktivität und wandel geht zum
beispiel ring der digitale wandel in
japan weit hinter den anderer länder
hinterher und um die sache noch
schlimmer zu machen hat die regierung
trotz ihrer absichten noch mehr
kontrollmechanismen eingeführt
so hat sie 2020 im parlament eine
änderung des devisen und
außenhandelsgesetz durchgesetzt um die
schwelle zu senken ab der eine
unternehmens transaktion der zustimmung
der regierung bedarf von zehn prozent
der anteile auf rund 1 prozent das
ergebnis all dessen ist dass der kauf
eines unternehmens in japan zu einem
fast unmöglichen unterfangen ausarten
kann was dann auch den relativ geringen
fluss ausländische direktinvestitionen
ins land der aufgehenden sonne erklären
würde aber all das könnte sich schon
bald ändern und zwar aus drei gründen
erstens zeigen umfragen dass die
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz von
ausländern die kontrolle über
einheimische unternehmen übernehmen
zunimmt etwas das in japan traditionell
für große angst sorgt angst welche man
schon als fremdenfeindlichkeit
bezeichnen kann damit wir uns hier nicht
falsch verstehen anders als zum beispiel
die berechtigten befürchtungen vieler
amerikaner europäer übernahme wichtiger
unternehmen durch investoren aus
totalitären ländern wie china oder
russland handelt es sich in japan
wirklich um übertriebene und irrationale
angst mit der sie sich selbst schädigen
es gibt viele beispiele dafür wie
feindselig brutal und alles so kriminell
die verkosteten innerjapanischen
netzwerke mit ausländern umgehen die im
land unternehmerisch tätig werden die
beiden herausragenden fälle sind hierbei
der nissan skandal um carlos ghosn und
der olympus bilanzskandal um michael j
[Musik]
beide geschichten sind wahrlich
unglaubliche wirtschafts und mafia
thriller die nicht nur eigene visuelle
predigt wie du es verdient hätten
sondern vielleicht auch gleich mit flex
ferien ich möchte sich hier kosten um
euch nicht allzu sehr auf die folter zu
spannen und auf damit ihr sie mit
welchen strukturen wie es in den po zu
tun haben der falcon ist hierbei der
prominenteste aber auch der umstrittene
und zweideutige hre der französische
automobilhersteller renault hat 1999
einen anteil von 36 prozent am damals
als straucheln geraten und japanischen
nissan konzern erworben er später auf
43,4 prozent erhöht wurde die beiden
unternehmen konnten eine enge allianz
der chef der brasilianischen armee sich
französischen renault manager carlos
ghosn wurde ws 2018 war er dann sowohl
chef von renault als auch nissan später
auch von mitsubishi motors an den nissan
2016 einen kontrollanteil übernommen
hatte den konzern als low cost killer
bekannt sanierte die japanische
traditionshersteller nicht sagen der mix
an der hilfe die die kehrtwende zur
profitabilität schaffte und cohen einen
zweiten spitznamen verpasste mister big
save
[Musik]
bonn wurde in japan zum helden und in
ganz asien als der geschäftsmann des
jahres gefeiert als einer der meist
respektierten wirtschaftsführer doch
dieses japanische wirtschaftsmärkten
endete jäh im november 2008 10 als grund
direkt bei seiner einreise nach tokio
festgenommen wurde ebenso soll existent
und nissan direktor craig kelly ihre
japanischen nissan kollegen und die
tokioter staatsanwaltschaft werfen ihnen
vor ihre einkünfte nicht korrekt
angegeben zu haben und mittel des
konzerns auf vielfältige weise zum
eigenen vorteil missbraucht zu haben und
bestreitet die vorwürfe vehement und
behauptet einsturz sei von einigen
wenigen nationalistisch zu
führungskräften bei nissan sowie
hochrangigen beamten des japanischen
industrieministeriums mit hilfe der
örtlichen korrupten staatsanwaltschaft
orchestriert worden um weitere
investitionen von renault-nissan zu
verhindern sie hätten ihn eine falle
gestellt und vor allem ein ziel zu
erreichen dass die franzosen auf gar
keinen fall den mehrheit der aktien an
nissan übernehmen können nun sind bis
heute weder die formel 1 noch der
anderen seite rechtskräftig bestätigt
worden nun mag vielleicht etwas zu
locker mit der firmen compliance gesagt
das bild welches hier die methoden der
japanischen managern behörden abgeben
ist jedoch eindeutig und bestätigt ein
klares muster der berühmt-berüchtigten
japanischen fremdenfeindlichkeit eine
un-arbeitsgruppe bezeichnete die
bedingungen der untersuchungshaft von
kameras grund in japan sogar als
freiheitsberaubung mehrere artikel der
allgemeinen erklärung der menschenrechte
seien verletzt worden es habe sich ganz
klar um eine willkürliche inhaftierung
gehandelt um rechtswidrig tatsachen zu
schaffen
hohenrode im april 2009 10 gegen kaution
von rund 12 millionen euro oder strikten
auflagen aus der untersuchungshaft
entlassen und floh dann auf
abenteuerlichen weg unter noch nicht
vollständig geklärten umständen in dem
dezember 2009 10 in den libanon der mit
japan kein auslieferungsabkommen
abgeschlossen hat und frankreich liefert
seine staatsangehörigen prinzipiell
nicht aus seine amerikanischen
fluchthelfer jedoch wurden von den usa
nach japan ausgeliefert und dort zu zwei
jahren haft verurteilt ein filmreifer
wirtschaftskrimi auf dessen fortsetzung
wer noch gespannt sein dürfen weitgehend
abgeschlossen und auch ganz und gar
eindeutig ist unser zweiter fall der
belasten da der olympus corporation
eines weltweit führenden hersteller
optischer geräte vor allem im
medizinbereich ich weiß dass vielen
fotografie enthusiasten der name olympus
vor allem zusammenhang mit kameras
bekannt ist aber diese und profitable
sparte hat der konzern längst abgestoßen
sein kerngeschäft spielt sich heute an
einem ganz anderen ende des menschlichen
körpers ab und wo ist dominiert mit
einem marktanteil von 70 prozent in
globalen markt für endoskopie und ob das
haupteinsatzgebiet der produkte auch was
mit dem charakter der topmanager zu tun
hat müsst ihr das beurteilen also hört
zu
[Musik]
denn fakt ist dass olympus in den 80er
jahren als die japanischen unternehmen
in den himmel gewachsen waren ihre
profite durch die starken gehen jedoch
immer weiter ab schmolzen vom gleichen
haid ergriffen wurde auf den auch alle
übrigen carey zu aufgesprungen waren
massive investments außerhalb des
eigenen kerngeschäfts
diversifizierung auf biegen und brechen
dabei wurde alles mit geld zu
geschmissen was nicht bei drei auf den
bäumen war der damalige präsident von
olympus gab selbst zu wenn das
hauptgeschäft ins stocken gerät müssen
wird durch saitek verdienen mit saitek
waren hoch riskante investments in
startups spekulationsgeschäfte mit
derivaten und allerlei andere gierige
verzweiflungstaten gemeint zum glück gab
es damals noch keine brücke währungen
aber natürlich ging auch so die ganze
geschichte wie alle halbs gehörig in die
hose und olympus versorgt auf diese
weise unzählige milliarden yen unter
anderem zum beispiel 2,9 lehrern die sie
in ein schneeball system gepumpt hatten
nun ja so weit so schlecht wer aber
meint es könnte nicht noch schlimmer
kommen wurde von der engen verschworenen
führungsriege und brust eines besseren
belehrt diese top manager kanzelte
nämlich nicht nur jegliche interne
kritik an ihrer riskanten strategie ist
halt und arrogant abziehen waren auch
danach nicht gerade große fans von etwas
was entfernt aus sowieso nicht sehr
beliebt ist gesichtsverlust also
versuchten sie alles um ihr versagen
beim zocken zu vertuschen und mit
wirklich alles meine ich massive
bilanzfälscher und bei der sogar yakuza
die japanische mafia mitgeholfen hat und
welche selbst die bayer karten wie
billige amateure aussehen lässt
[Applaus]
ihr genialer masterplan sah
folgendermaßen aus sie bauten ein
gigantisches geflecht aus scheinfirmen
auf in welche sie mit hilfe des
vorgetäuschten geschäfte ohne
gegenleistung kick backs und
überteuerter investments über viele
jahre hinweg geld aus dem operativen
kerngeschäft von olympus abstrakten und
damit dann ihre zucker schulden stück
für stück abzutragen die masche war so
perfekt aufgezogen das über viele jahre
unentdeckt blieb noch nicht mal von den
wechseln
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften oder
in das toyota bmw und doch dann
passierte etwas was nicht hätte
passieren sollen der langjährige chef
von olympus tsuyoshi kikukawa zog sich
mit seinen 70 jahren in den aufsichtsrat
zurück und rief den dritten michael
woodford zu 19 dieser war während seiner
30 jährigen karriere bei den japanern
von der britischen dependance bis zum
geschäftsführer der olympus europa
holding gmbh aufgestiegen wo dann das
ceo des gesamtkonzerns und schließlich
ebenso er war der erste nicht japanische
sumo von olympus womit das unternehmen
zu einem der wenigen von einem ausländer
geleiteten japanischen unternehmen vorne
[Musik]
aber warum man diesen schritt in tokio
eigentlich und gib mich lieber unter
sich nun offiziell hieß der kurs hamburg
wird der sich auf großer einer
überragenden managementfähigkeiten mehr
als qualifiziert habe als das neue
globale gesicht von olympus an berichten
zufolge ging es jedoch um etwas ganz
anderes der dritte habe den job nur
deswegen bekommen weil er durch die
japanische führungsriege als leicht zu
kontrollieren eingeschätzt worden war
einige japanische beobachter sahen and
words der kein japanisch spricht das
neue haustier von guido cover der als
graue eminenz so im hintergrund
weiterhin die strippen ziehen konnte tja
leicht zu kontrollieren das haustier
kikukawa und im übrigen verschwörer bei
olympus hätten wird nicht stärker
unterstützt haben können
[Musik]
er war nämlich von seinem deutschen
kollegen auf den artikel einer
japanischen finanzzeitung aufmerksam
gemacht worden indem verdächtige
zahlungen der firma untersucht wurden
und von da an ließ er nicht mehr locker
er stellte kramer und seine mitwisser
zur rede und als diese das ganze als
schmierigen sensationsjournalismus abtun
wollten engagierte er die
wirtschaftsprüfungsfirma
pricewaterhousecoopers um den
verdächtigungen nachzugehen und dann
ging es schlag aufgeschlagen
[Musik]
kikukawa berief eine notsitzung des
aufsichtsrats ein und ließ wird
blitzschnell entmachten und sich selbst
wieder als ceo einsetzen die offizielle
begründung der dritte habe etablierte
entscheidungsprozess ignoriert oder
zwietracht im management gesät nun ja
eigentlich das ja auch zu nach seiner
blitz entlassung wurde wird ford von
anderen olympus manager offensiv gemobbt
und fühlte sich und seine familie
bedroht da aus dem zeitungsartikel von
ihren connections zu yakuza wusste daher
verliest er japan sofort und flog nach
england nach tokio kehrte er erst zurück
als in polizeischutz zugesagt wurde um
sich dort mit ermittlern und olympus
mitarbeitern zu treffen eine weile
versuchten kikukawa und seine manager
noch alles zu leugnen und sich aus der
affäre zu ziehen und sie hatten dabei
sogar die unterstützung einiger
institutioneller investoren aus japan
obwohl diese doch selbst viel geld durch
den skandal verloren hatten unerträglich
lange hielten sie alle am konzept der
gesichtswahrung fest doch der empörten
liverpool aufgewachsene wird blieb
hartnäckig bis ließ nicht alles
aufgeklärt war die mannschaft um cover
zurücktreten und sich vor gericht
verantworten musste eine rückkehr auf
den chefposten bei olympus wurde ihm
dennoch nicht mehr ermöglicht er hatte
zuviel schadet über das ehrenwerte
corporate japan gebracht und
bemerkenswert war auch der hass leer
seiner familie entgegen schlug in london
erstritt er dann immerhin noch ein
schmerzensgeld in höhe von zwölf
millionen euro von seinen ehemaligen
arbeitgeber
[Musik]
die zelle nissan und olympus
illustrieren daher ein muster welches in
der japan ag lange vorher schon war und
ausländischen direktinvestoren zurecht
abgeschreckt hat aber nun könnte die
japaner ausgerechnet eine entwicklung
außerhalb der camps wo zu einem
drastischen mentalitätswechsel zwängen
der der demographischen niedergang sind
viele kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen zur schließung ihrer
eigentümer in den ruhestand gehen und
keine nachfolger finden können in einem
bericht des voerder ausschusses für
ausländische direktinvestitionen aus dem
jahr 2020 einem beratungsgremium der
regierung heißt es dass der zufluss von
ausländischem kapital hierfür die lösung
sein könnte wir dürfen das nicht
unterschätzen wir sprechen von mehr als
600.000 profitablen kmu in den nächsten
drei jahren möglicherweise schließen
müssen
[Musik]
dadurch sind nicht nur 6 millionen
arbeitsplätze in gefahr sondern vitale
lieferketten von denen auch die kehre zu
abhängen sie werden sich also schon
allein aus eigeninteresse mehr öffnen
müssen außerdem treiben pläne zur
steigerung des wirtschaftswachstums und
rentabilität der tokioter börse die
veränderungen in der corporate
governance politik der unternehmen voran
mafioso verschwörungen aller mpus sollen
dann geschichte sein wir werden euch all
diese zusammenhänge schon bald in einer
nächsten videos erklären also vergesst
bitte nicht visuell politik zu
abonnieren wo auch das glöckchen zu
aktivieren um auf dem laufenden zu
bleiben aber wer bereits oft oder
früheren videos betont haben handelt es
sich bei investitionen nicht um den
einzigen bereichen in japans wirtschaft
im bezug auf die wirtschaftliche
globalisierung zum außenseiter geworden
ist iran schon worauf ich hinauswill
aufgepasst
ein land das auch für talente
abgeschottet ist
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu den meisten
industrieländern leben in japan relativ
wenige einwanderer kaum zwei prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung in den usa als auch in
deutschland zum beispiel liegt dieser
anteil bei über 13 prozent das hat nicht
nur dazu geführt dass den japanern viele
talente durch die lappen gegangen sind
sondern auch dazu beigetragen die
demografische krise die das land erlebt
noch weiter zu verschärfen die
bevölkerung wird dann 2005 zu schrumpfen
und schafft seit 2011 sogar
kontinuierlich was einen hohen tribut
von menschen im erwerbsfähigen alter
fordert im jahr 2009 10 waren zum
beispiel mehr als 28 prozent der
bevölkerung über 65 jahre alt 160
prozent der japaner waren zwischen 15
und 64 jahre alt das erklärt warum
dieses land was den arbeitskräftemangel
angeht unter allen industrieländern am
schlechtesten da steht nach angaben der
japanischen regierung selbst werden bis
2030 etwa 65 millionen arbeitskräfte
fehlen
[Musik]
bislang wurden bereits einige änderungen
eingeführt um ausländische arbeitskräfte
ins land zu locken aber alles deutet
darauf hin dass sich die japaner in
zukunft noch viel mehr ins zeug werden
legen müssen damit hier nicht ein
fataler flaschenhals entsteht und der
punkt ist nun sowohl regierung als auch
gesellschaft haben dies erkannt und
deswegen ist im land bereits eine heiße
diskussion in gang gekommen eine
diskussion die das zeug dazu hat nippon
ordentlich umzukrempeln der schlafende
riese kündet dadurch erst so richtig
erwachen deswegen lieber visa-politik
zuschauer denken wir dass die japanische
wirtschaft sobald sie ihre
selbstdarstellung in jedem bereichen
löst in denen sie am stärksten von den
internationalen strömen abgeschottet ist
kurz vor einem großen wandel steht und
möglicherweise vor einem goldenen
zeitalter die frage ist jedoch ob dies
ausreichen wird um alle probleme des
landes auszugleichen wird japan das neue
traumziel für multinationale unternehmen
und internationale talente denkt ihr
dass japan wieder zur führenden
wirtschaftsmacht in asien aufsteigen
kann sobald ist ein fuß von der bremse
wma sowie oder diskussionsbeiträge zu
diesem themenbereich schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat oder vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt als ja gleich 1000
ihren freund und vergessen sie es aber
mit glück keines unserer videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich wollen das auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch ein
großes projekt und weiterzuführen in
paper li dazu findet ihr eine
beschreibung dem video als gut und bis
bald
[Musik]